January 1974 they just moved in two
months prior a partner and I were first
on the scene he was feeling for a light
when something bumped him that's when we
found the little girl hanging from this
pipe
I found someone to take over who'd be
very good for the BSU he wants to expand
the units and he intends to make our
approach practice so who someone you
want more than anything
Manson this is another time reported
missing in Atlanta sending you both want
you there for the duration
so all these children won't kill I
believe had to be the case it's
statistically rare for serial killers to
cross racial lines
she's also statistically significant
that the Klan kills a black people
getting out of there he blows this gun
will rethink his investment I'm asking
you as the leader of your department
what it always say that so offended the
city we need to stay focused if you're
distracting I have some things to deal
with it all it it's personal she had
someone else's underwear stuff down at
10:30 do you know where your children
this is one predator what if your well
I'm not very self-serving tor
we can't have tunnel vision holding the
what evidence is there to suspect the
Klan son
we've got 19 dead black children you
telling me that's a coincidence
one more thing man sent a small like
really small try not to stare
you